Hello and welcome to this special report
where we take a look at the big events
that have shaped our world
in the last 12 months.
I'm Angus Hervey, and this is the news.
We begin our broadcast with a story
that has dominated headlines
this past year,
Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
The war has inflicted
a terrible human toll,
plunging millions
into an unrelenting conflict,
dramatically upending
international politics
and sparking turmoil
in energy markets around the world.
Perhaps the only thing scarier
than a war like this
is the prospect of our planet
being ruined by climate change.
However, on that front,
the news has been somewhat better.
Specifically as a result of this crisis,
the global fight against
climate change has accelerated.
In response to Putin's attempt
to use gas and oil as weapons,
Europe has doubled down on green energy.
Last year, for the first time ever,
wind and solar overtook gas,
nuclear or coal
as the continent's largest
source of electricity.
And analysts say
that as a result of the war,
Europe's timeline
for ditching fossil fuels
has accelerated by up to a decade.
Staying with the climate,
in the United States,
a new law has committed hundreds
of billions of dollars of investment
into renewables and electric vehicles,
putting the country on track
to getting 80 percent of its electricity
from carbon-free sources
by the end of this decade.
And in the race to build
more clean energy,
China is way ahead of both Europe
and the United States.
The country is now installing
enough solar panels every day
to cover an area the size
of New York's Central Park.
At the current rate,
China will reach its climate targets
years ahead of schedule.
The energy revolution has arrived.
Global fossil fuel emissions
are now predicted to peak
within less than two years,
and the International Energy Agency
says that wind, water and sunshine
will become the planet's largest sources
of electricity by 2025.
To global health.
Where many countries are still struggling
in the aftermath of the COVID-19 pandemic,
less widely reported is the news
that last year, eight countries eliminated
at least one neglected tropical disease.
Top of that list, Togo,
which became the first country
to eliminate four of those diseases,
including trachoma, the world's
most common infectious cause of blindness.
Go, Togo.
(Laughter)
Today, almost 600 million fewer people
require treatment
for these diseases than in 2010.
It's thanks to the work of tens
of thousands of uncelebrated heroes
of public health.
It means that in just over a decade,
a significant portion of humanity
has been liberated
from a devastating burden of suffering
and from death.
There's also hope on the horizon
in the fight against malaria.
Last year, a new vaccine designed
by the University of Oxford
was shown to be safe
and incredibly effective.
Four days ago,
Ghana became the first country
to license that vaccine for distribution.
Nigeria followed
that up eight hours ago.
Both countries are now going to vaccinate
children under the age of three.
This is a world-changing treatment.
It offers us genuine hope
that we may finally be able to eradicate
one of humanity's biggest killers,
a scourge that has plagued our species
for thousands of years.
(Applause)
Imagine if this was the news.
(Laughter)
That along with all of the usual
death and disaster and division,
we also got to hear these,
the stories of hope and healing.
But not just another dog on a surfboard.
The thing is, this is the news.
These stories, they're happening.
It's just that we don't hear
as much about them.
But when you find them,
the world can suddenly feel
like a very different place.
Let's turn now to some environmental news
where pollution and degradation
continue to push Earth's ecosystems
past their breaking point.
However, in the last year,
humanity has begun to respond.
Four months ago, the countries
of the United Nations came together
to agree on a global pact to protect
30 percent of the planet by 2030.
And just weeks ago, after nearly
two decades of negotiations,
they agreed on the first-ever legal
framework for regulation on
and protection of life on the high seas.
(Applause)
The tides are beginning to turn.
Here’s conference president Rena Lee
announcing what Greenpeace has called
the greatest conservation
victory of all time.
(Video) Ladies and gentlemen ...
The ship has reached the shore.
(Cheers and applause)
AH: More good news for the environment.
Since the beginning of last year,
we've seen the expansion of protected
waters around the Galapagos,
the creation of an enormous
marine sanctuary west of Australia,
and a provisional agreement
between Canada's government
and First Nations
to create the Tang.ɢwan–ḥačxwiqak–Tsig̱is
Marine Protected Area
that will be Canada’s largest MPA.
That is just off the coast
of West Vancouver.
That's less than 150 kilometers
from where we all are right now.
Last year, Argentina
created a national park
around one of its biggest
saltwater lakes and wetlands.
Earlier this year, Ecuador created
one of the largest reserves in the Amazon,
in one of the most biodiverse
places on the planet.
And last month,
the largest river restoration project
in United States history
kicked off on the Klamath River,
led by the Yurok people of California.
(Applause)
None of it is enough yet.
But these are big victories.
They show us that destruction
is not inevitable
and that nature will recover
if we can just give it the opportunity.
This report just in now from our political
and social affairs editor.
Last year saw some significant
setbacks for human rights,
most notably in the United States,
where for many, it feels like intolerance
and polarization are on the rise.
Globally, however,
it's a very different story.
Since the beginning of 2022,
countries have abolished
the death penalty,
six countries have ended child marriage,
four countries have banned
conversion therapy,
four countries have legalized
homosexuality,
and 11 countries have actually
strengthened reproductive rights.
(Applause)
That includes India,
which passed a law guaranteeing access
to safe abortion for every single woman.
(Cheers and applause)
And Spain, which also protected
transgender rights
and became the first country in Europe
to provide paid menstrual leave.
(Applause)
Oh, and sorry, I forgot to mention,
Slovenia, Cuba and Mexico all passed
legislation on same-sex marriage
and adoption.
Three times --
three times as many countries
now grant those rights
to all of their citizens
compared to a decade ago.
(Applause)
The fight for equality continues.
But progress is happening
even if we don't hear much about it.
In the last year,
humanity has moved closer to a world
where everyone is free to choose
and free to love.
On that note, let's cross now
to some more economic news.
Many will have missed last year's report
from the United Nations
that India lifted 415 million
people out of poverty
between 2006 and 2021.
Despite some of that progress
being set back by the pandemic,
that still means that on average,
every day for the last 16 years,
a soccer stadium full of people
escaped poverty,
the worst kinds of deprivation.
That is one of the greatest
news stories of all time.
(Applause)
Let's cross now to our correspondent
in the field, Angus Hervey,
to get some more of these and some other
stories from around the world.
Angus, over to you.
(Laughter)
Thank you very much, Angus.
Well, I'm here in Brazil
where the new Ministry
of Indigenous people
is bringing much needed
food, hope, relief and aid
to the country's indigenous communities.
They've already deployed the military
to remove tens of thousands
of illegal miners
and restore justice.
Zimbabwe. I'm here with the Akashinga,
an all-female army
of wildlife rangers there.
These women, many of them,
are survivors of domestic violence,
but they have become formidable warriors
after years in the field --
Their military trainers say
they're more hardcore
than a lot of the world's special forces.
And they're really changing
the face of conservation here
and the other four countries
where they're operating.
They have hundreds
of their members out there now.
They're uplifting their communities,
bringing down poaching rates dramatically
and contributing to a huge rebound
in wild animal populations.
(Applause)
And finally in Bangladesh,
where thousands of newly-trained
midwives are bringing hope
and healing to those who need it the most.
Since 2012, they've helped bring down
the child mortality rate here
by almost 50 percent.
It is a powerful testament
to the work of midwives everywhere
and a reminder of just
what can be achieved
through education and a commitment
to improving the lives of others.
Angus, back to you now in the studio.
(Applause)
Thanks very much, Angus.
That was Angus Hervey there reporting
on everything from everywhere all at once.
(Laughter)
Let's turn now to science and technology
and what many say is not just
the biggest news story of the year,
but perhaps the most important
technological breakthrough
of our lifetimes.
ChatGPT has taken the world by storm --
(Laughter)
becoming the quickest technology
uptake in human history.
The power of artificial
intelligence is incredible,
but there are also very real reasons
to be concerned about its effect
on systems of power
and its impact on jobs and society.
As we wrestle with these dilemmas, though,
let us not forget
that in the last 12 months,
humanity has repeatedly shown
our resilience, inventiveness,
our capacity for expanding our knowledge
and ability ... to rise to meet
our greatest challenges.
Nine months ago,
we received the first images
from the golden honeycombed
18 beryllium mirrors of the
James Webb Telescope,
unlocking new secrets from the furthest
reaches of the cosmos.
Seven months ago, we smashed
a spacecraft into an asteroid
and altered its orbit,
confirming a newfound ability
to create planetary defense systems
against earthbound objects.
Four months ago,
we used freaking laser beams
(Laughter)
to recreate the conditions
inside of a star,
achieving more energy out of a nuclear
fusion reaction than we put in.
It's a milestone in our quest to provide
clean, limitless and affordable energy.
And then, just days later,
scientists in London announced
that they had used
a new form of CRISPR called base-editing
to hot-wire immune
cells and clear the body
of a 13-year-old girl named Alyssa
from an incurable form of leukemia.
(Applause)
It's an incredible medical breakthrough.
The first use of a revolutionary
new type of treatment
that may go on to save
millions of lives in the future.
So why is it then that outside medical
and scientific circles,
almost nobody has heard that story?
Why are we so familiar
with all of the stories
that make us feel scared or sad or angry,
but so many of these stories
come to us as a surprise?
Why are we so good at reporting bad news
but so bad at reporting good news?
That question is something that I spend
a lot of time thinking about.
I'm the editor of the Future
Crunch newsletter.
We share stories of progress
and what I've learned
after eight years of doing this work
is that progress is never a straight line.
Far too many still suffer
in poverty, from disease
and are trapped by conflict.
The struggle for equality
and the fight for justice
continues in so many places in the world.
We still have so much
work to do, to get done.
We know that geopolitical
tensions are rising.
Climate change is genuinely scary
and we are still destroying
too many parts of our planet.
But when we only tell the stories of doom,
we fail to see the stories
of possibility.
The hundreds of examples
of progress in human rights,
rising living standards,
public health victories,
clean energy breakthroughs,
technological magic,
ecological restoration
and the countless extraordinary
acts of kindness
that take place on this planet every day.
I believe that if we want to change
the story of the human race
in the 21st century,
we have to start changing the stories
that we tell ourselves.
And we have to remember
that hope isn't a noun.
It's a verb.
It's not something that we have
or something that we're given.
It's something that we do.
Millions of people around the world
chose to hope in the last 12 months
and then rolled up
their sleeves to get it done.
Perhaps it's time for the rest
of us to do the same.
I’m Angus Hervey,
and let's make this the news.
(Applause)